listen i gotta i got a good buddy of
mine i you know
i'm this close to telling him hey buddy
back off on the eye shadow come on i
mean i'm a kim i just i'm not i'm not
throwing names out there i'm like come
on alice cooper let's just calm down
how old is he i didn't say it's kim so
he didn't say it's kim but i'm tired
you think he's going to listen to this
don't tell he just mine he listens to
everything cotsie is
a year and three months younger than me
wow
kim coats and you met on black hawk down
and i'm black and you and him and eric
bana became really close friends
forever
just from that movie i talked to coatsy
almost the entire ride from the y to
here what do you talk about
you know we catch up he's been out of
town so
so
you know but coach he's also that guy
that you know
and i got a lot of close friends and and
i got one that i wrote uh my phone
called brook with king devore uh you
know king's like my little brother right
uh
you know because he's that guy we always
we got to have that one guy where
something's troubling me or something
i i i talked to coats about it
i talked about shitties put your knees
hey just we're we're those kind of
friends but all the movies you've done
yeah a handful of people you become
close friends with
you know
not more than that it's i mean you know
what it's like we work with a lot of
incredible people over time but you know
when you finish something that's no
guarantee that you're gonna you know
that you stay in touch life goes on you
know or you know there's only so many
hours in a day yeah and the people that
we're close to and you know and and then
i have kids and kids and you know all of
that so you don't get as many that that
are gonna be
you know friends forever you know it's
not like you don't you don't miss them
you know i just worked with some great
people in austin and who'd you work with
well i worked with ben affleck and i
have before right uh and i worked with
this actress uh would you work with him
on uh armageddon armageddon right
and uh i worked with this actress uh
elise braga and uh you would know her
from uh elysium and many things she did
this that series for five years about uh
uh they shot at new orleans shame on me
for blanking on it but she's uh
she's really incredible she plays the
lead in this um
you know you work with a lot of great
people and and you hope that you're
gonna you're gonna see him again you
don't know if circumstances are gonna
take you that way right you know
you